Marvel HQ is shining a light on
up-and-coming female stars in 2019 and
these young and talented actresses are
bringing a whole new meaning to the word
superhero watch until the end to find
out if duck airman will be reprising her
role as Gwen Stacy in marvel rising
chasing ghosts
Gabby Sklar Gabby Skaar might not be an
actress but she's managed to find her
way into the Marvel HQ squad the young
senior grew up in Long Island where she
dreamed of becoming the next big thing
and now years later she's well on her
way to becoming the star she's meant to
be in 2018 Gabby was given an
opportunity she couldn't refuse if you
loved marvel rising secret warriors as
much as we did you probably remember the
series hit songs stay true Gabby wrote
this catchy tune when she was only 15
years old
but despite knowing that it could one
day be a hit she held off on publishing
it and her decision eventually paid off
when Marvel HQ approached her with the
task of creating a future song for their
series Gabby was over the moon when she
found out that her song had been
approved but she still didn't know when
it would make an appearance during the
film but as she expected the movies
producers inserted it at the perfect
moment her song makes its grand
appearance when the heroes start losing
hope in themselves and it's motivational
lyrics help them gain back their
confidence we don't know about you but
we can't wait to see what the singers
next big hit will be Sophia Wylie Sophia
Wylie is a young singer actress and
dancer who brings a whole new meaning to
the word talent this triple-threat got
her big break by acting in the handful
of Disney Channel productions despite
only being 15 years old sophie has
already made a name for herself in the
entertainment business
in fact she's the singer behind Marvel
risings hit single side by side you
probably recognize Sophia from the
hilarious TV series Andy Mac the actors
play the role of Buffy Driscoll the girl
who everyone wanted to be friends with
the new year is bringing Sophia more
opportunities than she can count and we
can't say that we're surprised after all
the girls a star in the making she set
to play the role of RiRi Williams in
2019 s Marvel rising heart of iron this
TV movie will shine a light on her
character who goes by the alien
ironheart RiRi is iron man's partner and
she'll stop at nothing to save the day
when it comes to iron heart though you
could say that she's a brand new
superhero after all she made her first
ever appearance an invincible Iron Man
vol 3 which came out in 2016
Sofia is surely going to give her
character a strong yet hilarious
personality but we wouldn't expect
anything less from the star cierra
Ramirez tierra ramirez might be young
but she never lets her age get in the
way of landing big-time roles Ciara
began acting when she was only 11 years
old and quickly found herself starring
in Nickelodeon and Disney Channel shows
she's played parts in hit series like
zoey 101 The Suite Life of Zack and Cody
and the Fosters and now she's taking on
the role of a lifetime
Ciara is set to play America Chavez in
the highly anticipated TV movie marvel
rising chasing ghosts the actress who is
honoured to play the role will be
bringing sass and intelligence to her
character once again America Chavez who
is better known under the alias of Miss
America is Marvel's first LGBTQ
superhero and Sierra is super excited to
be a part of Marvel's newest line of
heroes during a Marvel HQ interview
Ciara explained how crucial her
character was in today's day and age the
actress went in depth about how Miss
America was diverse in more ways than
one and that this encouraged people to
be themselves as part of the new era of
superheroes Miss America has the ability
to influence young minds and her strong
and open-minded personality can help
point them in the right direction
Miss America made her first on-screen
appearance in marvel rising secret
warriors back in 2018 and the Marvel
community went wild so were curious to
find out what the new superhero has in
store for us next
Milana Vayntrub mallanna Vayntrub is a
talented actress who's no stranger to
success she's appeared in TV series like
this is us and House of Lies and now
she's bringing her marvel character
Squirrel Girl - brand new heights
mallanna landed the role of Doreen green
in 2018 and although her character only
made 3 small appearances during the TV
mini-series Marvel rising initiation
Squirrel Girl got a leading role in the
TV movie marvel rising strip warriors
later that year milania's character is
adored by the public which is why Marvel
HQ didn't hesitate to bring her back
mallanna is currently working on marvel
rising chasing ghosts which is set to be
one of the best animated TV movies of
2019 on top of that Marvel HQ is also
working on a new TV series titled new
Boyer's however they have yet to confirm
their release date the concept for
Squirrel Girl was developed in 1991
however the superhero has only recently
seen the light of day she's known for
her overly enthusiastic personality
which often helps her fellow heroes out
of a jam she's half woman and half
squirrel giving her a wide range of
abilities
she's agile quick super strong and able
to climb a building in record speed we
can't imagine anyone else but mallanna
voicing this wicked character can you
sky Jackson at only 16 years old actress
Skye Jackson is already being used as an
inspiration for Marvel's newest
superheroes Skye became famous overnight
when she challenged singer Azealia Banks
on Twitter during this time Skye was
already a proud member of the Disney
Channel family however her popularity
climbed to new heights after sticking up
to the internet troll Skye's strong an
independent personality inspired Marvel
artists to use her facial template as
inspiration when designing their new
hero
riri Williams but funny enough Skye
isn't the one voicing this character
instead she is known for playing Gloria
Grant a reporter who works in close
quarters with spider-man
Skye joined the Marvel HQ production in
2018 and now she's currently working on
the franchise's newest TV movie
alongside the rest of the cast Skye has
plenty of experience when it comes to
voice acting in fact she's voiced
characters in shows like Bubble Guppies
and Dora the Explorer Skye is working
closely with the Marvel rising star Tara
Strong who is the actress behind the
Mary Jane Watson character in fact when
it comes to Gloria and Mary Jane some
might say that these characters are
inseparable with the way things are
going Skye might be on her way to
becoming the most popular junior
celebrity in Hollywood the beloved
actress brings compassion and humor to
her character making her that much more
amazing Chloe Bennett Chloe Bennett is a
popular celebrity who is well known for
playing the role of Daisy Johnson the
star got her big break when she landed
the role
of Hailey on the hit TV series Nashville
however her career truly exploded in
2013 when she auditions for the TV
series agents of shield after locking
down Daisy's role Chloe went on to star
in a handful of Marvel HQ productions if
you don't know who Chloe is by now it's
only a matter of time before you do
because let's face it this girl is on
fire
Chloe spent six years portrayed her
character Daisy and agents of shield and
now she's currently working on Marvel
rising chasing ghosts Chloe is one of
the few actresses who managed to play
her character in both the live-action
Marvel series and its animated
counterpart she's appeared in every
single Marvel rising TV movie and is
loving every second of it her character
Daisy who goes by the aliases Skye or
quake is a highly lethal superhero on
top of being a skilled fighter with
enhanced reflexes Daisy can also
manipulate vibrations and anticipate her
rivals next move all in all this
superhero isn't someone you want to go
up against to think twice before joining
the dark side Ashley crystal Hairston
for the past nine years actress Ashley
crystal Hairston has been landing roles
left right and center she's played minor
parts and TV shows like Modern Family
and happy thoughts but the new year has
plenty in store for the young celebrity
for now however Ashley is dominating the
voice acting field which is why we're
not surprised to see her cast in one of
Marvel HQs upcoming series Ashley first
emerged in the TV mini-series Marvel
rising initiation
however her character ofrecerse turn
only appeared in one single episode but
this didn't stop producers from being
impressed by her performance so they
chose to bring her back in 2019 upcoming
TV series Avengers Assemble
Ashley is set to play bass a character
who is mysterious in more ways than one
not only do we have no idea if bass is a
villain or a hero we also aren't aware
of this characters powers so we believe
that Avengers Assemble will be
introducing new characters every single
episode which is definitely exciting
Amanda Miller is there anyone more
adorable than renowned voice actress
Amanda Miller we highly doubt it
although she might be a little older
than the rest of the cast Amanda is
excited to join the Marvel
and crew when it comes to voice acting
Amanda isn't natural and many of her
co-stars would agree that her voice is
as interchangeable as a chameleons skin
amanda is known for voicing Sailor
Jupiter in the popular anime Sailor Moon
however she's taking a break from anime
to lend her many talents to Marvel HQ
amanda is set to voice the character she
who is a relatively new addition to the
Marvel family in fact she's made her
first appearance in the comic book new
warriors vol 5 which came out in 2014
for the time being sheath is a
mysterious character who has set to make
a name for herself although she might
look like a villain we wouldn't be
surprised if she had a heart of gold
what we do know is that 2019 s marvel
rising chasing ghosts is going to be
jam-packed with some of the best voice
actors ever dove Cameron dove Cameron is
the obvious choice for Gwen Stacy's
character however the actresses schedule
is so jam-packed that some fans feared
that she'd have to drop the project but
luckily for us Duff would never consider
such a thing
in fact she's such a big Marvel fan that
she can hardly wait to get to the studio
the hard working celebrity instantly got
recognized when she joined the Disney
Channel family her talents led her to
play in a set of twins in the much-loved
TV series Liv and Maddie and before long
Duff snagged the role of mal in The
Descendants franchise these movies allow
the actress to showcase her singing and
dancing abilities so we're not surprised
that she's behind the marvel rising
theme song born ready this inspirational
song highlights the importance of taking
the bull by the horns so it fits the
superhero series perfectly on top of
singing the show's theme song dubbed
never fails to bring charisma to her
character Gwen although Duff is
currently filming for the Angry Birds
movie - and descendants three she always
has time for her favorite superhero and
were happy to hear it's because the
marvel rising franchise wouldn't be the
same without the one and only ghost
spider during a Marvel Entertainment
interview dove was asked about how she
felt about Quinn and the actress
explained that she loved Gwynn because
she was a strong and empowered female
character despite her young age dub is
highly regarded in the voice acting
community but we're not surprised by
this after all everything she touches
turns to gold so there you have it
Marvel's up and come
female stars of 2019 before you go make
sure to let us know who your favorite
superhero is in the comments below and
that's the end of our video don't forget
to hit that subscribe button for more
great content to come your way thanks
for watching and see you next time on
the things
[Music]